انضموا الينا من صنعاء نصر الدين عامر
نائب رئيس الهيئه الاعلاميه لجماعه انصار
الله الحوثييين مرحبا بك سيد نصر الدين ما
الذي اسفرت عنه الضربه الاخيره الغاره
الامريكيه الاخيره على موقع في
صنعاء نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الضربه
هي استهدفت مكان مستهدف يعني تم استهدافه
خلال سنوات العدوان على اليمن عشرات
المرات يعني لا جديد ولا اصابات ولا جروح
ولا خسائر لا ماتيه ولا بش
لكنها عدوان وانتهاك للسياده اليمنيه
واستمرار في النهج الاجرامي الامريكي الذي
يسعى الى خدمه اسرائيل ومنع اي تدخل
لحمايه الشعب الفلسطيني او لدعم الشعب
الفلسطيني نحن نعتبره جزء من هذا العدوان
ولكن الجديد فيه انه لم يكن هناك حتى
البريطاني اي ان هذا التخالف تفكك كما
يبدو واضح
وتحلل حتى انتهى وبقي الامريكي منفردا
وسيتحمل نتيجه هذا العدوان وسيتم الرد
عليه يعني في اقرب وقت ممكن ان شاء الله
ما المقصود بالرد عليه في اقرب وقت ممكن
كما يبدو الضربات الامريكيه وفقا
للتصريحات مستمره كلما دعت الحاجه هذا ما
يفهم من من التصريحات الامريكيه حتى
اللحظه نحن لن نسمح بان تكون بلادنا
مستباحه وبان الامريكي يضرب متى اراد نحن
لسنا ممن يقبل بان الامريكي يضربه ثم يسكت
ما زلنا لم نقم بالرد حتى الان على
العمليه العدوانيه السابقه التي يطلقها هو
والبريطاني وسيتحمل نتيجتها هو والبريطاني
وهذه الضربه الجديده سيكون لها رد حازم
وقوي وفعال يعني لن يفلتوا من العقاب
وايضا عملياتنا وهي الاساس عملياتنا
مستمره لمنع السفن الاسرائيليه من العبور
او المتجهه الى اسرائيل وما زالت القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه تقوم بمهامها على اكفا
حال وعلى اعلى مستوى لحمايه يعني لمن
ولتنفيذ قرار منع عبور السفن الاسرائيليه
وهو الاهم هذا ولكن ايضا هناك مسار موازي
الان هو عمليه الرد والانتقام لما جرى من
اعتداء وعدوان على بلدنا طيب هل هل سقط
ضحايا في اخر ضربه
الليله لا يوجد لا ضحايا ولا خسائر لا
ماديه ولا
بشريه لا خسائر ماديه ولا بشريه ولم يتعطل
لم تتعطل قاعده الرادار كما ذكر
الامريكيون
لا يوجد هذه القاعده لم تعد تعمل يعني تم
ضربها خلال سنوات العدوان بالاف ومئات
الاف الغارات يعني هي مكان مضروب مسبقا
ولا يوجد هناك اي خسائر ماديه وانما هناك
انتهاك للسياده اليمنيه وعدوان جديد يستحق
العقاب والرد طيب طبعا سنسال عن شكل هذا
الرد لكن في في اشاره هنا الى ان
الامريكيين يتحدثون عن فقدان جنديين
امريكيين في البحر الاحمر هل لديكم اي
معلومات
بانهما ليس لدي معلومات حتى الان عن هذه
القضيه ويعني اراقبها فقط من خلال الاعلام
لكن ليس لدي معلومات عنها وهي تتحدث عن
فقدانهم في مكان يعني بعيد لكن الواضح ان
هناك تخبط امريكي وهناك تفكك لهذا التحالف
وهناك الان عمليات منفرده لهذا التحالف
ولا ندري ما الذي يحصل في بالنسبه لهذه
الحاله من التخبط والخساره نتيجه هذا
التحالف الفاشل منذ اللحظه الاولى يعني لا
علاقه للحوثيين باختفاء هذين
الجنديين نحن لا نتحمل او لنا علاقه الا
ما نعلنه رسميا ونحن في حرب معلنه ورسميه
وما نقوم به من ضربات او عمليات نعلنها
بشكل رسمي وفخورين بهذه العمليات دعم
للشعب الفلسطيني ولن نتردد فعلا اي عمليه
تستهدف الامريكيين ونعتبرهم اهداف رسميه
ومشروعه ومن حقنا ان نستهدف كما استهدفوه
ولكن لا نتحمل الا ما اعلنا
طيب انتم سسته
يهدفون هذا يحيلني الى السؤال عن شكل الرد
طبيعه الرد
وشكله الرد هو من جنس العمل الجزاء من جنس
العمل من اعتدى عليكم فاعتدوا عليه بمثل
ما اعتدى عليكم نحن سنرد يعني الامريكي
استخدم قطع بحريه للعدوان علينا لديه ايضا
يعني مصالح في المنطقه والمقصود بها الان
هنا هناك سفن بح يعني امريكيه تمر عبر
البحر سيتم استهداف هذه السفن يعني بكل
تاكيد ايضا البارجات والقطعه البحريه
الامريكيه الحربيه التي استهدفت بلدنا
بلدنا واصبح وجودها في بحرنا في البحر
الاحمر والعربي ومضيق باب المنب لم يعد
وجودا طبيعيا وعبو امنا او بريئا وانما
اصبح هذا العبور عبور عسكري مسلح عدواني
علينا حمايه للسفن الاسرائيليه واعتداء
على بلدنا الذي لم يعتدي على الامريكي ولم
يعتدي على اي بلد سوى على كيان العدو
الاسرائيلي وسفنه اذا هذه هذا التواجد
اصبح استهدافه امر مشروع و من ضمن اله
يعني الدفاع عن النفس وايضا من ضمن وجوده
لحمايه الصف الاسرائيليه وهذا امر مرفوض
لن نقبل به شكرا لك نصر الدين عامر نائب
رئيس الهيئه الاعلاميه لجماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين حدثتنا من صنعاء